It was 10:30 on a Thursday night. And I was in my apartment
and I had just hung up the phone. I had been broken up with.
Yet again. By one in a string of
many five foot seven, rogaine rubbing,
Nintendo playing,
Beastie Boys listening, Hamptons
traipsing, New York
frankly. And I had had it. I really had it. And
I had had it
because to tell you the truth, I didn't even really really
like any of these
guys. Looking back I didn't like any of them. But I wanted one thing from them.
Just one thing. I
wanted a boyfriend. Ladies and gentleman. When you're in your twenties
and you're in New York and all your friends have bo- like having a boyfriend.
Gives you some legitimacy. You know, it gives and you can say 'Oh,
have you met my
boyfriend.' It was like owning
property. This, this is my boyfriend.
My boyfriend is taking me out for my birthday. My boyfriend is taking me
out for Valentine's. My boyfriend my boy, like a boyfriend.
But
the New York man. The New York didn't wanna, no one wants to commit.
You know they get the willies and they get all freaked out and I couldn't get someone to
be. [Sound of cellphone] Maybe that's my boyfriend.
I, I couldn't get someone to be my boyfriend.
And so
And so, I hung up the phone, and I was very depressed, and I decided I was going to go to an AA meeting.
I wasn't actually in AA.
I was in OA.
Overeaters Anonymous. But OA didn't have any meetings late at night. When I did the bulk of
my problem eating.
decided that I would
And so I decided that I would go to an AA meeting. I had done this a lot. When you're lonesome
you know. So anyway, I show up at the eleven o'clock
AA meeting over at Our Lady of pity.
on uh, seventy ninth Street and you know I, I go over there and I head into the church basement.
Everyone is smoking. And I pull up a chair and I listen to some former prizefighters tale of woe.
He killed a man with his bare hands
I dunno, you know the drill. And anyway I'm putting my coat on to leave
and I feel a tug at my sleeve. And I turn around and there's this guy he's about my
height and uh he's in a floor length leather
jacket. And he's got you know those cowboy boots that were very big in like the
early eighties with the metal tip. You know he's got that doin'.
And uh he had kind of a
weathered sort of a port of authority look to him. You know.
And he said to me in his, in this way he said, ah, "hey
What's a nice girl like you doing in a dump like this?"
[Laughter]
He didn't have cerebral palsy.
But he had like a
palsied affect. You know.
like a twitch. So uh.
He asked me if I would like to go out for coffee and of course I accepted.
And we got to know each other. His name was Steve Rubenstein
and he was thirty days off crack. And uh alright. Alright. That's a start.
And uh, he asked for my phone number and of course I provided it and he called me that night.
And he said "Dina I just want to say I think you're a really special
girl. And uh then he called me the next day
and he asked me if I would have dinner with him the next day and I said absolutely. And he picked me up in a Mercedes Benz.
And then the next day we went out for dinner again and he picked me up in a different Mercedes Benz.
And he, you know with a leather jacket
he said to me he said, "Deena, do you notice a difference between this Mercedes
and the black one?
And I said No. And he said, this one purrs.
And I, I think of him saying that and I was repulsed.
I was repulsed by him. But I thought to myself, this could be the one.
[Laughter]
Like, here he was you know, calling, and. This could be the one.
Because you know something, he was thirty days off crack notwithstanding. Steve Rubenstein.
First of all he was Jewish and at the time that was important to me. Various reasons.
But also
Uh, but also Steve
called.
Because when I got together with my friends for Chinese food and they all had boyfriends and they would say, "So, Dina, did he call?"
And, of course, I'd always say no. And then they'd have to give me that speech about how it's not you,
you know. It's . . . something must have happened at work, he's busy with other things.
No it is you. Like, it's you. You did, I did something to something
however small to annoy him, you know. I was sitting in the cab and I started singing,
singing, (sings) ....wanna, I wanna, I wanna play. Like that is all it had to be
And that was it. And you never heard from the person again. That was it. But Steve called.
Hello Deena,
it's Steve.
Alright, fine - but he called!
[Laughter]
Now I had been able to keep Steve at bay sexually for about three weeks.
Because you know I was playing the recovery card. You know what I mean?
Like look you know we're both going through changes. You're thirty days off the pipe, I have my food issues.
Let's
just, you know. And he was buying into it. And everything was OK for about three weeks there.
But finally at the end
of three weeks. You know it was time to pay the piper. He, Steve had needs,
and he wanted them fulfilled.
It's a literary event, so I'm trying to dance around.
But, alright. So.
We're driving in the Mercedes and Steve has his hand on my knee.
And it was spindly and cold.
And uh. And he says
he says he wants to go to my place. And at the time I was living with
a very surly taxi driver in his late sixties.
He was a guy I knew through a guy I knew I ended up in
this apartment and I knew he wouldn't take kindly
to Steve. And then Steve suggested that we go to his place
but I had been there once before and it was like the typical eighties cocaine guy
kind of apartment with all the black lacquer furniture.
And he had that ?Nagel? print from the Duran Duran album over the bed.
And I, I the thought of going back there I couldn't I just
and waking
up there was so horrible. So he suggested
that we pull
into a parking lot on the West Side Highway.
So he pulls
into the parking lot he and he rolls down the window and he says to the attendant he says,
"Listen I want to park all the way at the back of the lot alright.
By the water. Right?"
And the attendant says, "Well, what for?"
And Steve says,
He says, "I feel like fuckin' my girlfriend, if that's ok with you"
And
And the attendant like looks at me.
And I'm looking down.
And I'm staring at my knees. And I'm thinking oh my god.
Steve just called me his girlfriend.
Thank you.
[Applause]